the filter through which to see this
election is the individual parties not
going after some representative centrist
photo but kind of looking after their
own kind of interest groups and their
wider communities some of you have
fallen off to other parties and you can
see that today very vividly and we've
got this thing called sky data where we
had look at the views of 4000 sky
viewers representative sample this is
what they say about living standards and
this broadly reflects what we've seen in
other polls seventeen percent so it's
got better thirty-eight percent says
about the same 45% sets got worse so
doesn't matter what the actual
statistics say this is the best what
they think as justice a majority
basically thinking things have got a bit
work yeah I mean maybe not wildly but
but this explains some of what labour is
working with now if you say about a
future conservative or Labour government
labor come out marginally better than
conservatives on living standard so they
don't on the stewardship of the economy
on the issue of living standards they've
got something to work with now if we
take these guys and we if you like Sega
meant so so that's a 21-percent think
things will get better under labour yeah
but on the other hand 3810 things and
thinks things will get worse which is
slightly more than it is yeah they're
marginally they're magis marginally
ahead on this now if you segment the
people whose living standards are
staying the same or getting high or they
think that they are they tend to be
wealthier if we split it in the so
called mosaic groups alpha professionals
rural solitude careers and kids a BCG
that's that those are the groups that
will come back to that remember a BCG if
we look at the people who stands of
living are going down claimant
communities upper floor living there
called industrial heritage Terrace
housing these are the sort of five
groups now what the political parties
are doing right now is they're taking
these type of demographic data a little
bit more sophisticated actually
certification and they're mapping where
these people are and targeting their
messages very carefully at them so we'll
do a simple example of this if you take
that a BCG the people are doing Yale the
better off people there are people and
these are three of the constituencies
where they're most concentrated cheshire
more valley north east hampshire and
they're all areas where the
conservatives think they might even take
seats off the lib dem exactly and
actually there's nary there cuz lib dems
shouldn't
there we be benefiting if the economy is
doing well but the Conservatives are
making the arguin trust us with it they
try to take all the credit okay and but
if you take the people who are those I
JK groups these are these are two some
areas where they're concentrated the
Glasgow seats great grimsby both areas
where labour are trying to defend
themselves rather be you keep your and
then ants there insurgencies people who
are feeling the cost of living crisis
detriment defense that's where a cage so
in a nutshell where one group goes for
business and the other goes for low-paid
workers they're not really fighting each
other no no so so sort of if people
think what a labour doing with business
were they might be missing the point if
people say they know actually the Labour
Party's they will hang on we all do some
of a business we've got this you're not
gonna have European referendum
conservative saying actually we did
legislate on on zero-hours contracts but
in general I think it's better to see
this relax through a filter of can they
keep their core sport